let me see if she's still doing it  hello baby cookie  yeah  oh yeah you just always relax and laying  on your back in the middle of the floor  like a weirdo  yeah  you're such a cutie pie  [Laughter]  look at that where is she  she's right there  can't see her face  she's looking at the camera  looking at the camera  oh my goodness where'd you roll over  what are you doing  yeah  you just chilling on your back with your  little tail wagon yeah  you're awful cute  she's like why are you filming me this  is like the most natural thing in the  world  yeah  what do you have to say about that  what do you have to say about that pokey  not much okay  look at this little belly oh my goodness  oh my goodness  yeah  okay  you're so funny  little tail